pourquoi vous l'aurez compris mon job
c'est de vendre la suisse à l'étranger
alors promotion de l'image parfois la
défendre ça va mal faire mon job de nos
conditions qui doivent être remplies
la boîte pour ce cri joseph qui est du
contenu on ne pense à vous ensuite de ça
le problème souvent c'est se crispait et
silencieux il faut trouver des gueules
vous trouvé d'école qui permet de
raconter des histoires son pays sur ce
pays eagle d'incarner ce pays et cela
vient plus complet dans ce canton le
valais c'est un peu facile
un certain nombre de grandes gueules
j'ai un certain nombre d'histoires qui
me permet de gagner un peu plus facile
de vous présenter un petit voyage on va
les envoyer là les gueules du valais
les huit gueule que j'aime
personnellement qu'ils vous aient qui
nous ont aidés à fabu l'eau qui nous
permet de raconter des histoires
histoires qui font avancer ce prix j'ai
commencé par tous nous ont commencé cet
alex avec la montagne reste là ça va les
rendre les georges en et josé premier
kit valaisan qui a permis en quelque
sorte de se réapproprier la montagne et
vu les anglais ce documentaire c'est eux
qui ont la plupart de nos sommeils
l'équipe suisse cédée on les voyait
jamais avec cette génération de guy la
montagne ce qu'a appris on a pu raconter
des histoires
la fin de l'histoire sportive on a pu
finalement montrer que derrière ces
montagnes et des hommes et femmes en
décharge et partie de cette génération
qui sert à nous et qu'il nous manque la
home savez les guides aussi ont des
traditions sauvetage richard nationalité
ça me permet de présenter
mieux j'arrive paris marie bien à vie le
riz sur mon twitter selon l'option sur
les comptes twitter et facebook je suis
à côté de bari bar qui me suit partout
nous l'avons emmené à rio par exemple
monde ouvrier qu'on a une réponse est
pâle veille et les saverne a partout et
du vin valaisan a tout aussi est
notamment à rio et qui est très
intéressant que ces boules de poils et
sa super médium vous savez la vie vous
sont aimés ont fait partager des réseaux
sociaux sa légende
moi ce que j'aime raconter ou de voile
c'est la tradition la suisse humanitaire
à compter que ces bouts de bois lavandou
l'été la sauver les femmes et les hommes
pour être dans la bretagne cd + et paris
boxe comme vous le savez et c'est très
important parce que cette fille cela on
en parle de moins en moins plupart du
temps de la passion de la suisse tu sais
qu'au lycée partage pas c'est pareil
vous savez tous on est tous on a tous en
nous
ce gène de l'humanitaire ce gène des
solidarités je le rappelle en permanence
une fois qu'ils ont un peu bavé sur les
gens je le rappelle la suicidaire c'est
une scie à des médias qui fonctionne
bien communication comme les animaux et
y en a plein d'autres et il revient
certain nombre de médias qui fonctionne
notamment au sein la bouffe derrière moi
vous avez une belle femme qui vaille
farc
vous connaissez vous avez intérêt
connexes et un format de maison ils
travaillent avec nous à un milan à
l'expo au pavillon et quand lui nous
présente tard athlètes vont prendre
c'est à ce type là émouvant l'europe et
ne suis pas imaginer il te raconte lui
j'ai appris des trucs dont je vais dans
les clips des numéros et je vais
demander quand l'école est vache acquis
sur l'alpage de service assez importante
liga comme ça quand vous présentez
l'heure actuelle s'appuie fois moins
parce que tout le monde et vous ce
qu'ils disent et c'est la belle façon
cette façon film de vendre devant
reproduite dans leurs produits à voir si
j'en parle pas soi
selva j'aimerais voir un peu ce qu'on
doit la saison de l'ogc l'acheter vous
avez la mapa japonais bien parce qu'elle
a tellement dans l'abondant faire juste
un petit peu à gauche de même 20 de mon
producteur d'un abonnement la mère dit
harvey du monde mais grâce à sam ait un
char à glace avec les leviers on a en
quelque sorte un 20 ans tourner la page
de la monoculture intensive et dynamique
du fender et qui nous a permis de roder
histoire lorsque dans une ambassade de
suisse
lorsque la ligne officielle une raison
ces vins sont l'habitat sont l'ermitage
qui sont le moment ça commence à vivre
la marque vins suisses la marque d'un
suicide par le temps de ces produits-là
original on travaille on travaille à une
nouvelle façon de travailler la
biodynamique par exemple si ces
personnes là le voit est responsable on
va beaucoup je vous deviez le soir et
sont plus faciles alors la transition du
doigt frère saucisse
et je me suis dit comme ça est un média
bildt a forgé la boue enfin près les
animaux club real food de la moitié
parce que c'est vrai que chaque fois que
j'allais match de la carte sportive
lorsqu'on arrive à faire croire à l'idée
maintenance périodique d'où la tentation
des cessions au-delà tout nous peut on
sait ce que je pense que les sessions
autour le projet lorsqu'au balles ou les
manger lorsqu'on va est qualifiée pour
l'euro faisait le relais bien tout ce
qu'ils veulent investissements sur ses
marques les grandes gueules et ça va
incarner dans les frontières et ça va
incarner à l'extérieur des fonds pour
août qui n'est pas l'école qui savait
rien cardinal mathieu chimère c'est un
modèle pour moi le diplomate michael
sheen lbc partis de si grandes lomagne
au 15ème siècle bien compris que la
défense de ce territoire passer avant
tout la défense de la typicité de ce
territoire
sa neutralité passer avant tout une
disgrâce ea active ce qui place qui a
fini cardinal a su parfaitement jouer
entre la parité entre les rois de france
contre les italiens indiquent deux
violons envahir avec les allemands grâce
à ce type là le départ à partir en
suisse grâce à ce qui place on a inventé
il ya en suisse
donc ce type là un diplomate qui a aidé
à me garder ce territoire a créé le
citoyen suisse de plus photographiée à
la minute du monde
merci mon dieu les hommes politiques et
diplomates ont fait la suisse voilà
pascal couchepin haut de l'affiché dans
les salles aujourd'hui
ça touche pagenaud beaucoup il a permis
de faire ma carrière m'a permis de
comprendre l'importance du sens
politique et surtout j'ai joué très
impressionné par ce biais pas deux fois
j'ai toujours été impressionné par
quelqu'un qui savait connaissez les
valeurs de ce pays
la neutralité le généraliste
particularité aussi celui qui veut pas
qu'il veut à sa façon de faire partie du
projet européen du problème mondial et
ce type là il incarne avec force pour
lui voler tu ne dois être l'autre on
laisse donc voudra dire que j'ai
toujours été fier d'être à ses côtés à
moscou à paris à des gens comme ça il
pense que la modestie effet de serre
c'est une coiffure on peut respecter la
neutralité on peut respecter notre
vitesse nous devons respecter les forces
carney surtout elle pas avoir bien de
son mari
je vais finir avec j'aimerais finir avec
jean lassalle est du pays
le cfl gilles rabin fin géraldine
fasnacht ce que j'aime chez elle cette
capacité à dreuilhe clichés tombée
amoureuse notamment 10 oeuvres est
tombée amoureuse du servent à la cramif
à la nuit hier jeudi et se termine avec
son hymne soute
c'est jeudi de son serveur et tout ce
qu'elle a pu apprendre d'altec elle a
utilisé quelque chose
amicale probablement boutique demain sur
un cliché de yens dans cette cinquième
saison que vous que mon port qui pensait
d'eux allait connaître la vallée
d'afghanya combine fonds dans les années
maintenant la migraine ex pas foule
c'est pas faux mais puisque j'aime bien
cette ambassade ou cela cette capacité à
respecter ses clichés il faut pas les
passions c'est notre identité il faut
pas les aimiez éperdument stupidement
manière générale non dynamique jouer
avec vous jouez avec ces identitaires le
produit faut les aimer faut parfois des
tày mais faut les respecter
ça ça et ça ça m'a apporté un truc qui
est très important général mais aussi l
après la poésie sa façon de voler dans
sa façon des mines d'alès a cette touche
collectif
tout ce que vous avez en vous la vie en
vous l'avion du polonais robert de la
cible la notion